okay let's get started
for those watching this live stream this
is a design review meeting internal
software architecture discussion today
continuing our life in the trees looking
at symbolic representations of trees and
more from language intended for the next
version of Wolfram language so should we
get started where do I start hitch I
just evaluate this first few things yeah
the garden last time we stopped that
tree objects and grits
so the third section okay okay we have
two simple one which is tree graph it
takes a tree and returns a graph okay so
we've got this rules tree concept that
is going from rules to a tree and then
the question is to go from the tree to a
graph and this I see it has vertex names
so if I were to go so if I do this if I
say tree is rules tree of that graph is
that and if I say this if I say graph of
that comma vertex labels arrow automatic
then I'll get that exactly
it's cool okay so here tree graph is a
symbol that we already have in system
but we decided to add this functionality
for the tree demon tablet what about the
option vertex naming yes so this is
something we we mentioned last time so
the idea was to find a way when you do
the conversion from Twitter graph to
shoes what will be the vertex names of
the graph so by default it is automatic
and as you can see in the input form you
get the name of the tree of the tree
nodes
if you go further done we can change
these two Alexa is this what is this
graph ABCD those are those are strings
yes
no those are not strings what are those
these are the name of the vertex of the
law I see I see I see I see sorry of the
symbol names of the vertex okay so wait
a minute what is Charles's point here
well essentially the adding new option
vertex name so I'm wondering how we work
with two node or that type of input I
mean you name what what is vertex names
what is it - that's a new option in
eleven eleven three vertex naming naming
he was just adding so I wanted to know
how we learnt the retreat you know all
that type of thing but Maya's adding
that what what yeah so the name was not
decided yet the IDS that we wanted
something to say what will be the name
of the nodes in the graph so this is a
temporary name vertex naming of the
nodes in your destination graph yes
exactly and and why do we think they
need to be renamed I mean it is there a
graph theoretic way of renaming them no
but you might have repeated things you
know like you know you have tree right
right I remember this discussion right
in order you know and so you know one
thing that you can do when you build a
converter if you need some kind of
control over that mapping that function
that provides if you want some control
you need a function that provides that
control I agree otherwise we're gonna be
doing some crazy thing you know a a 0 a
1 a 2 type thing right but so what is
the default if if I were to give ok so
let me make this more difficult I mean
for instance it could it could
completely ignore what the node names
are in the tree and just use 1 2 3 4 you
know a canonical numbering and then just
purely use those as labels that's
another choice it can make yes I agree I
agree I mean that's which is not totally
stupid in my view so ok so then we've
got one with repeated stuff right
okay so let's now
so what happened there so this didn't
what did it do
it just didn't label the ones I see the
ones that were repeated it didn't label
but what the heck am I going crazy here
what did it do
oh-oh-oh-oh because they don't know it
is the same yeah right okay fine yes
okay okay when it is set to automatic
it's going to try to take the name of
the three notes and if there are
duplicates it will ingest to take the
index or um yeah so I think by default
graph is using a them so this is a
depth-first ordering for the naming the
vertices now you give them as input
there is no choice if you specify that
tree using those names or those symbols
that's what you get Roger this is the
case where there are repeated values
here III just said that there is a
solution to that and that's you know in
the conversion is where you can control
if you want to repeat a value which is
completely valid we can have a tree with
repeated you know node names the head
ombudsmen melt that's perfectly valid
from that from the design point that we
do now it's not valid as a graph you
know they need to be they're gonna
structurally be the same
they gotta be unique you know I
understand it but the point I think
Xavier was making is this is a
depth-first traverse
no no it is coming from the input of the
vertex list the way you give it we don't
do it that first others for the naming
what do you mean it's go in so the way
he killed the graph so if you call it
you know one to tie so you might beat
one two three four
but there are some symbol that generates
some graphs directly and there isn't
automatic naming for them is it correct
you mean even something like carry tree
or something generates what does carry
tree is so if I say carry tree of you
know 10 comma 2 and then I say that
thing vertex labels
- automatic but there's nothing you can
count on I mean this deaths no a tear
that's that's using it's done
I understand although I mean there would
be something you could count on which is
the part apart numbering scheme which is
not what this is no it's not that's of
integers right yes
on some kind of traverse it's it's the
graph index you know everything as an
index fine I mean we clearly need to get
more sophisticated about re-indexing
graphs when we do graph substitution and
so on has that been has it been looked
at yet I don't know we don't do graph
substitution what are you talking about
no I I know but we've talked about
design for graph substitution okay then
then that doesn't exist yet no I
understand that but when we think about
relabeling graphs graph substitution is
one of the applications for graph
relabeling hmm right and so in
particular you know something where you
you you know a node you you give birth
to nodes right and every every time you
give birth to a node of to kill it you
know like like every vertex could turn
into 3 nodes for example sure and then
we we have to have some scheme which I
don't think is completely unrelated to
the vertex Rene renaming scheme okay so
the proposal here which was on the table
was to have a vertex naming function are
we going to call it vertex naming or
vertex naming function
buddy I mean and the idea is that is the
thing which maps from what from the part
number in the tree this seems like a
very general name for something that is
I mean in a sense this is a very
specific thing about tree graph right
that well that was my point that you
cannot it's specific to actual you are
three element is not specific to think
of the the the relabeling yes what's the
other case where you make a graph from a
from a tree element tree I mean isn't
isn't this the function that makes
graphs from tree element trees this
would be true ref right I know but I'm
asking is there anything else that makes
a regular common or garden graph from a
tree constructed from tree elements
because Charles was making the statement
that this is really associated with the
tree elements yeah I mean I'm wondering
if there's if that is true because you
know the graph of vacation of the tree
maybe there's only this one function
which does that glorification we discuss
it at some point having an expression
graph which may run into the same issue
yeah we'll don't we have an expression
graph here no here we could do a squish
on tree and then tree worth I say okay
but but expression tree we should have
and it will run into the same as here
didn't Georgio work on an expression
graph thing yes and what what is the
status of that so this is very similar
to what we have currently for expression
tree oh I see I see I see I see
expression tree but here we actually
return it tree truly meant objects
rather than a group okay but if I do an
expression tree of something like this
okay then I get that and if I now say
tree graph of that and then I say graph
of that with vertex labels what is going
to happen
I see so it didn't even make an attempt
even if this had had I see a minute it's
it's implausible but it could
conceivably have had unique labels for
everything here perhaps this is a case
in which you have to separate the name
of the vertex and the label of the
vertex okay do you have a separation for
that in shabby I think well yeah but
there was some issue in that photograph
sorry okay so wait a minute what what is
the difference okay so name of the
vertex in the original tree element
right there's there is a name sub
element in the association that is the
vertex data for that right yes yes okay
so what you're saying is that name is
not adequate to be the name for the
graph for the graph element whether
we'll be getting some echo on this some
line if somebody is able to adjust
themselves
um the okay yeah so the issue is you
when we have nodes with the same name so
this was the main idea of having some
option that can control this I mean I
think the option should be attached to
your tree object and when you do a tree
graph on that then vertex label
automatic will interpret it based on
that they shouldn't be attached to thing
off well but Charles you're never gonna
think of this I mean there's no obvious
place to attach it to the tree element
stuff I thought it's got a options
general options don't eat it does but
this is a global issue I mean doing
vertex naming based on index or tree
path is a global thing for the whole
tree
perhaps what Charles is saying is that
the graph should have names which are
basically the positions which are
uniquely defined and then the graph
automatically should peak as a label
names and then it doesn't matter whether
they are repeated right I mean our first
prototype West fashion graph was
essentially doing the same to d4 Georgia
started to take it so essentially we you
know we use position and then you play
with option to manipulate what you want
the label or the name or such okay so so
your proposal is that rules the tree
graph of the rules tree just blows away
these names here but puts in the names
as labels for the graph is that right
yes I think that makes a lot of sense to
me a lot of sense that seems like the
right thing and if you don't want the
names you just say vertex I mean in
other words if you want vertex labels
you put in vertex labels if you don't
want them you don't you don't yeah
so I think that's fine you say you can
save vertex now the problem yeah right
that should be fine so you're putting
them in as vertex labels correct in the
graph created by tree graph there is a
setting for vertex labels which carries
over the names from the original tree
and then you can happily everything's
repeated and it's just yeah it's it's
fine but this is the correct design okay
look at happy with that so what would be
so either the name of the vertices do we
index in for the graph I think we should
end X term like this index term whatever
your canonical indexing but now we can
talk about that sequence and Roger or
anybody else do you want to discuss what
that sequence should be this is a
depth-first traversal ooh the tree isn't
it
I think it's an input order I think it's
not it doesn't yet know the structure
when it picks the index but so what do
you mean by another because you're gonna
you know if you give a set of rules if
you give a you know a set of nodes and
then set of rules there is an order in
which when you I see but doubt that's
determined by how Xavier generates that
order from rules tree ok so what I'm
asking you then is from rules tree
you're doing the depth-first traversal
to get generate that order but probably
it shouldn't matter as long as all the
labels have four different indices no I
understand doesn't matter but you might
as well get it as right as we can that
is that seems like a sensible ordering
right but I was just thinking that carry
tree address below is actually doing it
which first order so maybe I should
fruit this one instead well and actually
for a special on Twitter was something
we pick because it's kind of roughly the
evaluation order tool so which one
depth-first or breadth-first depth-first
okay but notice that carry tree is using
breakfast traverse yes
that one was Josie choice I don't think
it was I mean you did something special
about it
okay the other possibility is to give a
name which is the position and the
position specifying the index that are
used by graph you shouldn't put too much
into them the the only property that
they needs to satisfy is that they are
unique you're unfair no there's no you
know because you're gonna mangle that
tree in all kinds of ways you know and
you transform it and so it's fine ok so
the only issue is in the case of an
expression tree there is a certain
argument that we should give the part
number as the default name of the as the
default identifier for every for the
elements here right and so the question
now the only question that we have
really right now is again you know in
your list here where you give the index
or the tree path
could conceivably give the tree part
instead of an index here I don't know
what the difference does it make I mean
I I think we should just give the index
first thing and maybe subsequently we
can figure out an option to change that
if it seems important make sense to
people yeah okay I think some use cases
will then say hey it would be cool if
you could do this automatically you know
because there's some right particularly
useful and it's kind of ordinary to to
do yes agree all right let's keep going
here okay yeah so here this is just to
to show you the reverse of what is the
graph root is that is that an option in
um in graph at this point or is that a
new option that you're adding for the
sake of being able to disentangle these
where is graph form to come from is an
option in graph which is not documented
it you know when were working on
actually having quoted three on with
that cough but since we didn't propagate
the fortunately why we really haven't
documented it okay do we like the name
it worries me when we have square roots
of graphs and goodness knows what well I
mean wouldn't it be better to say graph
root node or something or do we not
sailed graph root vertex
yeah probably God would vertex is very
size 32 synthetics okay can you have and
I that does seem like a useful option I
mean it's an option for relevant for
drawing layered graphs right and it's
the thing when we were talking about in
that equation or proof business when
we're talking about how to determine
what the roots are in a layered graph
this would determine it right right I
know effect actually a lot of things
like you know but first ed first harder
sell because you need to have a hoot
layouts also okay also graph root
doesn't but it gives you an default that
you can start on if you don't give it
right right okay so we agree graph root
vertex its can we rename and we could go
ahead and document it I guess
okay um okay so let's take a look here
so if I don't give the
Groff root here what happens is going to
decide which node is taking to take the
root so it should be the first in the
list so we get the same output okay but
if I were to read enum real label if I
were to do a rotate right or something
here um oh wow
that happened to give us that's gonna be
confusing here whoa why did it do that
does it know what does it know here does
it who figured out that that the root
node is a here well it's looking at the
oh maybe no maybe it's actually looking
at the yes it's looking at the edge I
think first let's say that I add here a
you know a C goes to C edge okay some
random thing and now I say graph tree of
that yeah I understand it I understand
it's not a tree why don't we just say
position one why are we saying it that
way we should just say I mean the fact
that it's a position one is this is to
ponder I mean it's two kind of pseudo
precise Jose helps a be a clean up this
message but we use that quite a lot I
mean that that type of structure yes but
only when there are multi argument
things and oh I see what yeah yeah okay
I mean you kind of know um yeah and also
we're not supposed to say should be a
tree graph Q object it just says is not
a tree okay wait will you present
message okay um okay
all right let's keep going here so what
is this now this is a rules tree okay
and then that becomes the tree graph of
it and then we have the graph tree of it
and all of those properties of so okay
so that raises the question if you have
a graph and the nodes aren't named yeah
what happens as you make a graph tree
from an unnamed graph if you understand
what I'm saying so let let me let us
always have indices for sure yeah I
understand it so if I do carry tree 10
comma 2 for example and then I say graph
tree of that
yes so the warning will be removed but
yeah it's taking the the NDC's okay
that's not completely crazy except what
is this weirdness look look look look at
the ordering there let's take a look
here okay there's our carry tree and for
some reason it did a flip arou here yes
yes this was yeah
this is a bit difficult to control
actually well it can it really depends
how the words for the edges are given
initially in the graph so it's going to
read each of them one by one in the
order that are given so we may not end
up with the same Lauren go ahead is a
layout issue hi I noticed that the wall
but you know yet having some time you
know with the adjacency matrix so
similar adjacency matrix we don't
control exactly the you know rotation of
this stuff it's easily out for coffee
issue I see I see it's not an issue of
the numbering no oh I see yeah yeah
you're right the numbering is correct
the two is on the two is part of the
bigger brownish yep okay all right okay
I get it
I mean you know Charles there might be
an argument to look like take a little
glance at the actual naming of the nodes
and see if there's a lexicographic order
that will disambiguate during layout or
is that nuts well dick I mean doesn't
make so the kids where he's down you
know pure in this numbers like the
sequence of integer even if it's
lexicographically or durable I mean even
if it was strings it's not completely
crazy it would at least give some
canonicalization to the whole thing okay
all right any other issues with graph
tree this looks great
I mean okay now you're talking about
undirected graphs yes so we already
talked about that in a sense root of
we've given undirected graphs
unspecified
okay but you can determine the root
vertex right if it is a tree you can
determine the root vertex yes it may not
be unique no no that's what I'm saying
this one has many roots you could start
anywhere yeah yeah okay well you can
determine a root vertex right let me let
me take an example so if I'm not
mistaken fine spanning tree is the thing
which will give you a tree associated
with one of these graphs is that correct
yes and so so for example if I take look
what can I get a random Cayley graph or
some other cool thing what's it what's a
good graph guys just give me a graph the
hand on class may I don't want to random
graph I want to grow up around rattle
granite things golf whatever I'll take a
round of golf you said you wanted a
random grill I know I know I know
okay all right there we go so fine
spanning tree of that how can I have how
can I have disconnected vertices of it's
a spanning tree
it's a spanning forest yep so when do
when is not to connect it Spanish
components yes okay all right well let's
let's go like this blue okay what do we
do here so we say connected components
what we would have to do then is to say
connected components of that line right
how do I do this what is the thing for
just getting the graphs graph connected
component Oh connected
I think it's connected graph component
blah it's kind of messy okay one two
five oh okay great
by the way Charles are you doing this
thing of sizing the graphs based on that
content yes there were filmed it you are
working but it isn't but that hasn't
that isn't something that has been done
in this in this output is that correct
yeah you know done okay fine
do you have reasonable heuristics worded
we need to talk about them kind of
fighting prototype and when I will have
something with you probably have a
meeting and discuss about it okay fine
all right
so boom let's craft read that okay so
the first one is happy happy the second
one should that work I think it probably
should what's wrong with the tree of
OneNote no issue watch okay we know what
the root is all right that's just a bug
probably all right I'm pretty happy with
Groff tree any further issues of the
Gogh tree okay and we got quite a bit
more to do with those tree okay so three
rules yes so the idea of trolls it that
you give it a tree and he's going to
output the rules that make the tree okay
what is this complicated thing here yet
rewrite X should be remove its we
treatment but here it's working with
Twitter tricks okay this is simply you
specifying a tree you specifying a tree
and in the the words that you get you
can have actually further information on
the node so for instance you can see
that our goes to and you have something
which either which is a style of the
vertex I don't understand that what is
that thing is that a tree element
yes since this is a last note that you
can see just below our it's a red node
yeah okay so if I look at the input form
this is a bunch of tree elements
yeah so here against tree vertex but it
will change to treaty month but yeah
this is the case so the main idea is
that you may want to add some properties
to the node this is a decorated so that
your point is when it is just a name
when the only thing in the tree element
is a name you strip it to just be the
name in the in the tree rules and when
it is decorated you have the full tree
vertex exactly okay I would argue that
we should have some function that
determines what happens that is this is
the automatic setting but I can imagine
places where I would want to fluff the
tree vertex even if it has no or tree
element even if it has no extra
properties to make it if consistent
shape to the other things and I can also
imagine cases where I would want to just
drop the properties making sense so here
I was using a single argument in tree
wolves which is basically the key yeah
yeah yeah that's nice so I mean
automatic for that would represent
although or the one argument form or
automatic yeah okay you've already got
this problem solved I mean I agree with
the solution and the default here is
basically name is that right
the default is no the default is this
automatic behavior which which flushes
out you know if you need to okay so so
wait a minute the only way to get
everything is to say automatic or is it
all here I think it's automatic you say
they're two element and you get two
elements back that's a little weird
because remember that's usually the key
like the property name by the way that
should it be allowed to be a list of
keys okay let me let me suggest two
other settings automatic means do the
stripping
thing if it's just the name okay and all
would mean just come back with the full
tree element in each case am I making
sense yes Chevy arrow say have you guys
looked at and I think that there's
something we could do here reasonably is
to have sort of a you know an elysian
behavior for the layout part so we have
like a cloud there in the middle and you
can still see the leaves you know or or
you know two levels down below to the
cloud or something like that you know
however we decide to elide some part of
the graph yeah you're suggesting that
you drop the labels who dropped the
decorations here yeah but but the other
thing I mean even more drastic drop
whole sub trees in the layout that we
did we look at them because then we can
have a more surgery like operation to
see what part of the structure do I
really want kind of see I mean it might
be a future type of functionality but I
think that that would be kind of really
powerful particularly when you don't
work on just toy size trees you're
suggesting this as a display mechanism
or yeah yeah is the display mechanism
but if we are very happy with the
display mechanism that might be
something that we actually encode in the
structure so that it's the default
display magnet so you don't have to
specify it every time
well so are you suggesting that you'd be
able to click to you know open a subtree
Oh eventually but I was thinking of even
programmatically or you know the markup
wise and code that what things are
visible and what things are not right
because what what it would probably
allow one to do but I I think I guess
where you have to experiment with it is
to you know skip many layers of a tree
and then sort of start seeing structure
in the beginning start seeing structure
at the end and it might be might be
quite powerful well okay so vary in size
there are two places which are similar
to that one is expression folding right
code folding and expressions which is a
similar kind of thing yeah and another
case that I would potentially argue for
is graphs you know take this sub graph
and squash it which is essentially what
you're doing in like the system modeler
world you're essentially saying take
this sub graph and make it a single
black box
yeah I'm not mistaken we also have power
mullet its way left on placated for
graphs and in case a system modeler it's
left to you know that's theirs first of
all quite elaborate and it's it's sort
of restrictive of what you can and
cannot you know know and for graph to
specify what the interface is it for a
general graph it's it's way harder than
for a tree no I understand we've also
got this in net graph and in neural
networks we have it we already have a
mechanism there for displaying right I
mean you know you can display the you
know went when I generate a neuron that
right from that model for example um if
I look there to this one
what the heck is that
that is a new bizarre thing that I've
never seen before so it's just a chain
that's also a tree if it's just a chain
no but it's not because it has these net
grafts underneath it see oh I see which
have all kinds of junk in them what is
this
Sushma do you know what this is the
summary box that's that's something
daddy worked on and he is he wants
graphic design to look at it and we will
do it as soon as graphic design gives us
at the same time okay I think what he
has there is entertaining whimsical and
crazy okay that's those are the three
adjectives I would use okay well I think
this is an I mean this whole question
about folding and elision is one we
should talk about can we put that let's
separate that off from this yeah I don't
think it's necessary but I think it
would be a good they will be great notes
plus okay here are you really giving him
missing without anything in it yeah I
was wondering which stream with their
well we don't don't we say key missing
don't we say good we're thinking of
Whitney actually the name of the key
that was given in doesn't that what
naturally happens I mean if I'd given
Association and I say you know some key
here I don't I get that key absent car a
yes but one issue actually was that if
we take it again this rule and we use
whole story on it
my interpret the missing as vertex name
and is going to go down in the
expression of the missing if you see
what I mean
yes I thought you meant that's horrible
yes so this was the issue or maybe we
can make all Street itself well no we
can't I was even can make it not looking
inside a missing expression but walk me
through this again so a rule three
why would it go inside I mean it's only
looking for rules if the expression tree
might go inside but rules tree will just
look for nested rules won't it no yes
that's correct
hey let me ask you another question what
about a 2-way rule what are you doing
with those are you interpreting a
two-way rule in any useful way for for a
for tree rules for them
is there something it could mean I mean
it's more like a grand directed yeah
right but I mean what does that mean in
a tree to be undirected trees I mean
undirected trees are perfectly well
defined fair enough then maybe you
should just treat two-way rules the same
as rule for these but for now Sariah
yeah indeed agent you don't think it's
working though fine okay so what are we
saying here so right now we don't care
about this missing and it should just be
a key absent missing is that correct
yeah anybody anybody object to that
anybody see a problem with that no okay
all right let's go on tree insert okay
so we started talking about this last
time as I recall and the concept here is
you have a tree remote expression in the
first argument the single argument is it
shree object you want to insert I mean
it sort of a shame because in a sense it
it's much cleaner if you can give a list
of rules saying insert this in these
places but I guess that would be more
like a tree replace part do we imagine a
tree replace part
we could do that yes yes we could think
about that I'm not sure it's useful but
tree insert I mean it although maybe it
seems like a more natural syntax than
this okay but so let's take a look here
so this is saying given the particular
tree path associate yeah insert a node
I am very confused here insert a node to
become that tree path is that correct
yes
so the tree is labeled by an association
rather than by lists at every level what
what then happens so here we go to the
first position in the Association but
what's its key did you understand what
I'm asking
I don't think actually it's an
association we still have a notion of
what's the first what's the second we
just yes but there is the issue of what
will be the default name for the right
which has to be non overlapping with
anything else
and what Noth do we do if we wanted to
do it based on the index number but
there happens to already be an
association element whose key is one for
example then we're in a bad shape well
no we have to displace them as we do
with expressions no but but if the
actual if somebody actually had their
association with with you know 10 11 12
as the keys
it would be pretty obnoxious of us to
just pick up those keys and change them
I mean one assumes they were there for a
reason a worst case you know these you
know we fill in a lot of nodes and they
just had number 101 was there and that
101 meant something completely different
who's got a good idea what to do okay so
what should we do
I'm confused so so you're talking about
the situation in which you have three
keys and one of them happens to be two
and then we say insert at position two
no I'm not saying that I'm saying that I
think it's an error but
we have other numbers and we say insert
of position three you will count the
third key in the cessation and not just
insert number three you know we have
several other people who have been
remarkably silent but maybe they have no
opinion about this okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry do you think you have a solution
here what are you saying no no I'm
trying to say that we make we do that
they eat their obvious cases and even in
the ambiguous cases we give errors well
one possibility could be to give the key
in the second argument maybe so he goes
to treatments if we were to insert in an
association but what if the three
elements itself wants to be the rule a
goes to B or something but don't we have
this problem already in Association
itself inserting in an association sure
we have all kinds of things that deal
with doesn't associate in have in
association don't we have a whole bunch
of pruning options and things how does
it work doesn't start to work in
association that's a very basic question
let's answer that question okay so let's
try um
let's build an association a goes let's
say he goes to one B goes to two and
let's say insert X at position a what is
a foreigner station you have to either
key value pair
yes okay interesting
okay X goes to six and what what is it
doing for the third argument there so
it's really before the key named oh no
you know what that's doing that is
saying we're in the look watch this see
that tells you the the sequential
position in the association at which the
thing will be inserted oh I see so if
you said B it would insert it in the
middle that's right but if I said if I
do this if I say BR oh six it's going to
overwrite look tree insert you do the
same as insert does and it should insist
in the same way what you were basically
saying name do that the second argument
in the case where it's inserting into an
association element it should go ahead
and insert it at a position
corresponding to the last argument with
an association form that is this now if
we're doing it with multiple things I'm
a little bit confused what happens if we
have multiple elements and I think we
should look at what insert does in the
case of multiple elements there okay
what I'm saying because I think that's
looks confused to me I mean if you said
multiple positions there and you have an
insert and you say BR oh six positions
you know three and four for example
that's even more confused let's do do
wouldn't you oh I see but what it's
doing is it's just overwriting all right
I think tree insert should follow insert
okay let's continue we have quite a lot
more to go over here let me just take a
look um so here you have a tree and you
give a rule or a list of rules to
replace it freedom and expression to
another water so we could yeah was
wondering if we will also merge this
tree based part that we've just talked
about we also wish to replace its
infantry okay so let's look at three
replace here so what you're saying is
that this is taking three elements with
names II although hopefully we can just
say Z here yes
what on earth is this
that's all I see that's its self a rules
tree I see so this is saying now if if
the left-hand side here is a subtree or
is this just a single element that we're
replacing a tree replace it's a cemetery
for you but a subtree as in you label
the sub tree by its top node you would
have to give all the sub tree a tree so
here why why do you have to give the
whole subtree I mean if you're replacing
well I mean how do you reglue let's say
I replace there's no D with something
right let's say I replace it with a
two-legged animal right how do i reglue
this thing onto the two-legged two legs
of the animal yet this was a issue if
you D by n as a treatment expression
with children the way the issue of what
do you do with oh I think you get rid of
it I see okay I mean I would have
thought that this is a subtree
replacement thing and that you go to a
particular node in the tree and then if
you really want to replace that node you
know you extract the subtree you do what
you want to do with the children and
then you you Reeve insert as the subtree
the thing that you got you get what I'm
saying
they see anybody wants else want to
comment on this in other words that tree
replaces a subtree replacer that takes
tree now the question is does it take a
tree you know is the is the first
element of tree name which might be non
unique right and then it would be the
analog of replace presumably if I say
replace of X Y X X X goes to a what
happened there it live in one
okay fine so that's the analog of tree
replace I would have thought tree
replaced part was the one that would be
well I'm a bit confused here so if I
remember correctly what we wanted to
have is a pattern on the left the left
hand side has to be always at three
elements so that we say C underscore
there is no doubt about whether we are
referring to the name only ordered food
key element and then we extract parts
from the tree element and put them back
on the right hand side even in it and
what is the canonicalization of the tree
element that's used for the pattern but
I don't know something because there two
cases that we're interested in one is
replace the subtree at tree I mean maybe
this is irrelevant at tree position we
have a tree position function don't we
well but if we have a three element and
data sub trees we can have a pattern
that takes the sub trees and put them
back put them back in the interaction
side so so we will reconstruct the sub
trees and then in the process we change
however we want the data
right so here we are entering again the
area of of patterns of three patterns
which is difficult and will have their
day the president of graph button so so
we are we do not have the president of
God exactly so we have an unexplored
area here which is difficult but we want
it to be simple and just have three
element on the left hand side always and
you extract the parts that you want from
it and put them back on the right hand
side and that's I don't think we can
solve this problem in this in this
moment here let's just take a quick look
forward at these things and we are going
to have to meet yet again about trees
but let's let's just see if we can okay
I consider this a somewhat unsolved
problem I think we need to get it more
carefully yeah that's what difficulties
ok tree extract that has a paths back
and what are you proposing for the paths
back so here we have this problem of the
relation between part and extract and we
wanted to have a design that mixes both
so we can have a list of arbitrary parts
and that said the f2 path so two paths
identifies a single position inside the
tree and a list of triples is a list of
positions inside the tree ok what if the
what if the branches at a particular
node are labeled by keys and an
association rather than sequentially the
department takes the keys
that's one okay so he's got a number
school so wait a minute so how does it
does that McGee right between children
and a key there are some keys that are
special especial
but look if we say generation I see so
you're saying generation arrow - meaning
two generations back or forwards and
force for I think it has to be future
generation versus past generation
doesn't it yes why don't we accept a
negative as one sorry
yes yeah so long as we can remember
which way round it is right what is in
an ascendant you know I have to say my
thing would be to call them successors
and predecessors I think those words are
extremely obscure Thanks I mean
ascendant you know strikes me as being
you know it has some kind of faintly you
know when when you know Venus is in the
ascendant or something or Capricorn is
in the ascendant I don't even know what
those mean there's some kind of
astrological you know over life um so I
think those should be predecessors
because I think predecessor is very
clear okay predecessors
how can it be predecessors its
predecessor saw right well all of them
above entry I see but there's also
predecessor which is just parent right
okay predecessors and successors which
is equivalent to subtree yep
hmm well name of the predecessors in a
tree I mean there's another name good
not really a subtree is a single tree
element containing things successors is
a list of all their successors this is
slightly different thing okay
possibly that okay all right so what
you're proposing here oh my gosh
yes so here we are we are trying to mix
the power of often a part of
specification and extract a
specification as together with
extensions that we have seen in things
like XPath SiC cetera okay well let's
look at it for a second but let me just
understand this what is this querying a
subtree okay there's our subtree yes so
this is a basic version which will do
basically the same thing as to extract
but I set values of the tree element
object so you can specify the version we
need to clear a pada if it's a stream
now it should not be necessary right I
think we try to imitate the data set
here right sorry yes exactly and so it
also has a select mechanism it may be
you not implemented for this values but
yeah okay so okay this is encouraging so
we're getting close to the end here of
this design um so the one thing that is
really complicated is this tree extract
thing not so much a struct as the
pattern they're replacing I think the
replacing is more difficult than the
extraction okay but if you've if you've
specified so but the replacing is going
to require it's an extract and insert
operation isn't it well know one thing
is replacing by name another thing is by
position like replace part replaced part
this is easy once we settle on the
language for
decisions but they look for something of
this structure that's the difficult part
and canonicalize does a tree element why
is that so difficult well it's it's how
we use patterns and whether the pattern
reference refers to a full tree element
or only the data whether we allow
pattern on the decoration options this
sort of thing right um it's not even
clear whether we will need in the
eventually a tree element pattern um
sorry I I lost focus here because I
realized we're late for something else
um you know what we we need to look back
another meeting let's start with this
this question about tree paths but I
think other than that we are in pretty
good shape here you agree is anybody I
mean is this is going to require a full
team I'm afraid to talk about this so
we'll probably have to we'll have to
wait until after Thanksgiving which
doesn't give us a hell of a lot of time
to get this stuff finished um unless we
wanted it less people around tomorrow
and we want to try this tomorrow but
what do you mean finished I mean the
plan is to have these as a prototype for
some time not enjoy a certain all right
okay okay that's a shame wouldn't be
least have it be a loadable package in
eleven three
I'm not sure I think this this is going
to fundamental functionality and it's
worth ference amps a lot more around our
own internal use let's have it be a
loadable package just so we can play
with it even if we don't document it
we're trying to have it in external is
that enough so that we cannot play with
it in external mm-hmm
even better if it was in the main thing
but as a as an undocumented unloaded
package we can do possibly even a packet
that could be updated alright so several
of you I think are in the next meeting
which will start in about a minute here
and for those of you who are still
surviving on the live stream we might
see you in the next in the next next
episode same same channel same whatever
they say I don't know what they say I
don't watch television maybe they don't
say the same thing anymore because it's
all expected to be streamed or something
ok talk to you talk to you soon